hey guys I'm so excited because clearly
as you can tell by the title of this
video it is the best iOS sticker for
iMessage that you could ever find and I
am gonna be completely honest with you
I'm 100% biased because there I just
dean stickers and not just iJustine
stickers that they're also DJ Minnie
Matt stickers and a couple other of my
favorite things so let's take a look at
them but before I get into this I'm
excited because I've never had an app
before and technically it's not really
an app but technically is an app I've
always had so many fun app ideas and
it's just it seemed like such a hard
process and I never did it but the
sticker thing to me has just been so
much fun and I've had a ton of fun using
other people's stickers and I was like
all right we need to make my Justine and
Maddie stickers thankfully these
stickers were made before my dog got a
haircut cuz right now he looks like a
little tiny rat Maddie do you look like
a rat I love you know I love him so much
to get the stickers I will put a link in
the description and you could also just
search for iJustine in the sticker store
the first things first I started a new
Apple ID account where you guys can
actually send me messages I'm going to
be doing a separate video reading some
of your messages and also picking a few
of you guys to FaceTime call so very
very important here's the email address
I just need stickers at gmail comm
basically you can put that into your
iMessage and you can send me messages so
I'll be calling some of you guys who get
the sticker pack and also send me
sticker messages with them so I'm
excited to see your messages and I'm
kind of excited to see how this whole
Apple ID account works out I'm pretty
sure it's gonna break my phone but that
will be incredible maybe I should do
like a live stream maybe that would be
more fun so how do you get the stickers
there's a link in the description but if
you've never used iOS stickers before
I'm going to show you how to do that as
well so you're in your iMessage here you
hit this little icon here clearly I've
already got them installed but if you
hit those four little dots right there
you go to the store and there's this
little search up here so you can just
search for iJustine and there they are
of course they're already installed but
you can just click to buy them and then
once you download them and install
you're able to use them and what
things that people I think that haven't
really used stickers very much don't
realize is that you can put stickers on
top of each other these are my favorite
sunglasses ever so here we go and I can
put things on top of the sticker by drag
and dropping as you can see by this
little display of a massive sticker mess
so if you guys want to tweet me some
really cool screenshots of you guys
messing with your friends with these
stickers I will not be upset about it
this is probably also one of my
favorites it's like a little Maddy with
this little coffee cup I love it so much
like I actually like I cried when I saw
them for the first time like little
Maddy is just the most handsome little
dog ever I'm gonna see if he wants to be
a part of this video so this is Maddy
he's a Swedish dog ever I love him so
much
he just got a haircut because his hair
was a hole kisses it's your summer cut
hmm are you excited about your sticker
so that's really all I wanted to tell
you guys today I'm just extremely
excited because they are so fun and so
cute and it makes me so happy just to
see a little Maddy I've been sticking
these stickers all over people's chats
basically just in sending them to Jenna
and it's really great because if you
happen to be a blonde girl you can
probably pass this off as you so you can
say hey look I've got my own emojis say
something where's Jenna oh oh yeah I'll
show you are Jenna's you can also make
them enlarge there we go ha ha ha a lot
of people don't know that you can
actually stick stickers over top of
people's text so when I first saw that I
was like this is in a bee crate that's
it I hope you guys love them and as I
said at the beginning of the video I'm
going to be doing some FaceTime calls I
might actually do it live which could be
kind of crazy but all you have to do is
send an iMessage to iJustine stickers at
gmail.com send me some really cool text
some of the most creative ones that you
guys have made using my sticker pack I
will either take screenshots or I'll
text you back or I'm not sure how this
is going to work because I've never made
a public account like this before so it
could go really
terribly it could go really well but
we're gonna find out either way I'm
super excited about these tickers and I
just I'm so excited I can't even it's
been so difficult for me to just not
tweet and just talk about it but I
wanted it to be sort of a fun surprise
and a fun little reveal so today is the
day it's today oh so excited thank you
again for watching and thank you so much
in advance for getting the stickers this
has been so much fun and I'm so excited
to see you guys use them out in the wild
and if you do love them make sure you
guys leave a really nice review on the
App Store
I will also be reading those in the next
videos so thank you thank you thank you
I love you and I will see you in the
next bed so bye
I'm dancing I'm dancing should I do it
no no no you're not allowed you are not
allowed I was gonna say I should go
dance to celebrate in the Apple Store
but no Justine you're cut off you were
cut off those days are over
no they're not yes they are no they're
not oh but I'm fighting with myself
Phil
feel
[Music]
okay